[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne trois ans de préparation 37
millions de foyers concernés par une
réforme qui est en débat dans le débat
français depuis 60 ans le prélèvement de
l'impôt sur les revenus à la source va
être une réalité dans quelques jours au
moment où vont notamment arriver les
fiches de paye du mois de janvier alors
que le ras-le-bol fiscal n'a jamais été
aussi fort en france l'exécutif et les
services des impôts n'ont pas le droit à
l'erreur le ministre des comptes publics
a d'ailleurs déclaré récemment faire
confiance au bon sens des français
majoritairement favorables il est vrai à
cette réforme
alors que va changer vraiment cette
réforme l'administration fiscale
redoutent elles des bugs les entreprises
sont elles prêtes
sommes nous prêts finalement et que
va-t-il se passer quand les salariés
vont découvrir leur fiche de paye
amputée de leurs impôts on en débat avec
nos invités ce dimanche en direct
benjamin jaxx bonjour vous êtes député
la république en marche de saône et
loire membre de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale et
ancien chef d'entreprise c'est important
dans ce contexte geoffroy secula bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de l'ash
de la branche industrie de la ceppm côte
d'or
merci également d'être avec nous étienne
lepage bonjour vous êtes le directeur du
pôle gestion fiscale de la direction
régionale des finances publiques
michel faivre picon bonjour bonjour vous
êtes membre du comité régional de la cgt
merci à tous d'avoir accepté cette
invitation vous qui nous regarde et vous
pouvez bien sûr commenter cette émission
en direct avec le hashtag dit mme paul
bourgogne sur les réseaux sociaux
évidemment je le disais à cette question
et dans le débat public depuis 60 ans
elle est mise en place benjamin dire qu
au pire moment à une des plus graves
crises sociales que n'a jamais connu
notre pays
ça tombe mal pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi ça tombe mal pourquoi puis
envoie maintenant on a un appeau qui va
qui va aujourd'hui s'adapter à la vie de
chacun je crois que finalement c'est ce
qu'on entend aujourd'hui s'adapter à la
vie de chacun
ça fait plus de 100 ans depuis 1914 que
cet impôt existe et on le paye toujours
avec un an de décalage
ballan jour il va se passer quoi il va
se passer que pendant l'année vous allez
peut-être tomber je vous le souhaite pas
avoir un arrêt maladie vous allez avoir
des enfants
vous allez avoir plusieurs petits
boulots et bien l'impôt va pouvoir
s'adapter à cela on a en france plus de
7 millions 7 millions de personnes qui
ont une variation de leur revenu
supérieur à 30%
c'est énorme et ben on va s'adapter aux
besoins mais quand on reçoit notre fiche
de paye même si c'est psychologique on y
reviendra
on va voir un être inférieur et on aura
versé sur votre compte en banque
anne est inférieur à celui qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et vous savez bien que la colère des
gilets jaunes ils étaient encore
nombreux hier dans la rue elle vient à
la base d'un problème fiscal
alors on aura déjà peut-être un aide qui
sera supérieur à celui qu'on avait pas
au mois de décembre avec toutes les
mesures que je viens danser président de
la république et qui ont été qui ont
qu'on a pu mettre en place
et puis on le verra peut-être pas de
couilles et puis dont je continue et
puis surtout il faut prendre l'ensemble
on a aujourd'hui déjà seulement 43% des
français qui payent l'impôt sur le
revenu et sur ces 43 % de français 60%
sont mensualisés donc paye déjà l'impôt
tous les mois et sont mensualisés sur
dix mois ils seront maintenant
mensualisés sur 12
donc c'est bien un gain de pouvoir
d'achat par mois et en plus ils payeront
cet impôt à la fin du mois alors
qu'avant quand il était mensualisés sur
les 10 mois c'était en milieu de mois
donc c'est bien un gars qui passionne
les gilet jaune est bien compris comment
ça allait se passer du côté de la cgt il
y avait du monde dans la rue aussi ces
derniers jours michel faivre picon
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette réforme ton mal on viendra je sais
que la cgt est depuis le début contre
cette réforme est là le contexte est
vraiment j'allais dire terrible pour
cette réforme non oui le contexte
intérêt puisque le prélèvement à la
source ne répond pas aux rebelles
fiscale ou un besoin de plus de justice
fiscale qui a été exprimée avec les
gilets jaunes bien sûr mais également
depuis des années on a le système
d'impôt direct en français est un
système une usine à gaz est compliqué et
on aurait pu profiter de l'occasion pour
réformer complètement là la fiscalité en
france qui n'est pas le cas et là
effectivement
la réponse qui est amenée avec le
prélèvement à la source n'est pas du
tout à la hauteur de la situation
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être pas une
réponse benjamin diax mais exactement ce
n'est pas une réponse n'a pas la source
est quelque chose qui était déjà parti
avec l'ancienne majorité dont la
repousser d'un an pour être sûrs d'être
bien en place et on en parlera plus tard
je suppose dans l'émission maintenant
qui est une une fiscalité complète à
revoir en france que qu'il y ait la
nécessité d'un consentement commun à
l'impôt qu'on ait le sentiment d'un
impôt juste et payer justement par tous
j'en suis d'accord mais là pour le coup
c'est bien pour ça qu'on a lancé le
grand débat
je me suis pour ma part responsable
fiscalité pour la majorité je suis très
attaché à sa mais laissons les français
s'exprimer mais si on attend tous est
constamment va pas forcément avancer là
on était près tout le monde avait fait
des efforts pour se préparer pour ce
mois de janvier pour le prélèvement à la
source y avait aucune raison de le
repousser
parmi ceux qui ont fait les efforts il
ya les patrons on viendra après à la
problématique vraiment de des chefs
d'entreprise dans la collecte de l'impôt
finalement mais sur le contexte quel est
votre point de vue joffrin secula de
ras-le-bol fiscale et cette fiche de
paie que vos salariés vont voir dans
dans quelques jours amputé de l'impôt
directement donc ils auront moins deux
mois de net
et puis surtout moins d'argent sur le
compte en banque même si c'est vrai que
pour ceux qui étaient mensualisés il
leur versait ensuite leur contexte pour
les entreprises je dirais toute mesure
qui vise à augmenter des charges pour
nos entreprises ou bien un impôt on y
est évidemment défavorable
on transforme les entrepreneurs en
collecteurs d'impôts en lieu et place de
l'état
donc c'est bien une charge
supplémentaire qui vient s'appliquer aux
entrepreneurs pour ces raisons on y
était évidemment défavorable ce contexte
vous avez l'impression que ça va jouer
oui ça va forcément ça va forcément
jouer puisque il y a un effet
psychologique on a pu avoir l'occasion
de faire des simulations avec les
nouvelles fiches de paye au mois de
décembre dans pour certaines entreprises
et les premières réactions sont de dire
ouh là là je m'attendais pas à autant
alors effectivement sur le montant on
peut en discuter
on est sur un même montant d'impôt si ce
n'est qu'il ya un effet psychologique
est important de prendre en compte alors
on va en parler justement avec étienne
lepage la réforme et benjamin district
disait elle est essentiellement
finalement technique elle ne change pas
grand chose sur le fond on paiera
toujours la même sorte d'impôt à la fin
de l'année c'est juste une
réorganisation qui est juste ça n'a pas
été si simple je le sais mais c'est ça
en fait le plein c'est une réforme de
simplification administrative à une
réforme technique c'est pas une réforme
fiscale est effectivement pour les
personnes qui étaient mensualisés
allières finalement ça change pas grand
chose si ce n'est de gains le fait que
ça soit étalé sur 12 mois au lieu de 10
et le fait que ce soit prévu en fin de
mois et non plus en milieu de mois donc
voilà papa de réforme fiscale une
réforme de simplification technique
qu'on a ardemment préparer ces dernières
années et qui pour l'instant se passe
très bien on va y revenir
évidemment cette hantise de voir le
pouvoir d'achat baisser même si c'est
psychologique sur la fiche de paye vous
n'avez donc pas peur que ça ravive la
colère des gilet jaune
non je vous ai expliqué pourquoi parce
qu'on a déjà passé beaucoup de mesures
la suppression de cotisations chômage et
maladie les 100 euros supplémentaires
pour les personnes jusqu'à 2000 euros
d'ailleurs des personnes des personnes
seules les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées et c'est ma place
énormément de mesures dont je suis pas
inquiet pour le pouvoir d'achat mais
pour répondre à ce monsieur je comprends
que les entreprises au départ
puisse se dire c'est quelque chose qu'on
me demande en plus ça vient d une danse
y avoir des prises
voilà c'est bon c'est des choses je ne
laisse supposer aussi ces questions mais
au final l'entreprise elle collecte déjà
à l'impôt elle collecte la csg elle
collecte la tva les pee wee elle
connecte déjà l'import et puis on a des
fichiers qui existe aujourd'hui un à dsn
qui étaient déjà là et on va on va
prendre ce fichier là pour pouvoir
transiter la déclaration sociale
nominative part dans l'adsl et donc
comment passe par ce fichier en crée pas
quelque chose de nouveau
l'administration fiscale a fait un très
gros travail et on l'a vu avec plus de
150 personnes ayant sociétés ayant des
logiciels comptables pour être sûr que
logiciel puisse s'adapter
le travail a été fait avec les
entreprises vous l'avez dit sûr à
moi-même sur trois mois pour voir que
les personnes on va y revenir rendre
bien compte donc je suis plutôt je suis
plutôt confiant confiant on va y revenir
dans un instant à la préparation des
entreprises des salariés puis de
l'administration fiscale mais le
prélèvement à la source c'est quoi
exactement et les mondes réponse tout de
suite avec marie-pierre courtellemont et
marie joly prendre 7 millions de
français plus de la moitié d'entre nous
est désormais concernée par cette
révolution fiscale
le prélèvement de l'impôt à la source
vous savez un prélèvement mensuel donc
quelque part j'ai payé au fur et à
mesure et trouve que paiement à la
source est aussi bien il va falloir
réduire considérablement
son train de vie donc le pouvoir d'achat
depuis le 8 janvier
les retraités du moins ceux qui paient
l'impôt sur le revenu ont été les
premiers prélevés sur le versement de
leur pension et dans quelques jours ce
sera au tour des salariés d'être
ponctionnés sur leur paie les employés à
domicile pour on peut attendre l'année
2020 premier de cordée dans ce nouveau
casse tête les chefs d'entreprise la
plupart d'entre eux ont eu le temps de
se préparer
la nouveauté sur cette fiche de paye
c'est cette ligne là qui tient compte du
montant de son impôt sur le revenu
tous les collaborateurs or on est déjà
prélevé de l'impôt et du côté de bercy
on assure que tout le monde est prêt
techniquement oui l'administration
fiscale et les interlocuteurs de
l'administration fiscale les éditeurs de
logiciels les entreprises sont prêtes
centre est techniquement
certes mais il y à l'aspect
psychologique les économistes
s'attendent à une baisse de la
consommation dès le mois de janvier est
surtout en février pas de quoi réjouir
le gouvernement en ces temps difficiles
alors étienne lepage vous aussi comme
les entreprises avaient eu le temps de
vous préparer mais est-ce qu'on doit
craindre des bugs des ajustements des
des choses perfectibles
à la fin de ce mois de janvier c'est à
dire finalement la semaine prochaine
quand on recevra tous notre fiche de
paye pas en l'occurrence pour les
salariés tout à fait on est on est
confiant on est raisonnablement confiant
il faut il faut savoir que de
prélèvement la source est déjà devenu
une réalité en fait pour une grande
partie de la population les retraités
les retraités on l'a entendu l'âge elles
ont distribué en début de mois les
indépendants enfin les professions
indépendantes les et les commerçants les
artisans ont été prélevés le 15 sans
anomalies sont bugs et donc vous avez
déjà versé de l'argent aussi c'était le
15 janvier le même jour on a aussi versé
l'état versé pour plus de 5 milliards
d'euros a à peu près 9 millions
d'usagers
c'est la trésorerie pour tous ceux qui
ont des déductions fiscales des impôts
exactement c'était
c'était au départ prévu pour 30 % ça a
été élargie à 60 % en septembre dernier
et donc ça s'est fait sans aucune
anomalie
donc c'est ce précédent et déjà très
positifs et nous rend confiants pour
effectivement l'échéance importante de
femmes ou alors on doit à qui on doit à
l'administration fiscale aux entreprises
cette absence d'anomalies pour l'instant
non il faut alors juste sur ce qui était
dit effectivement là on a bien versé au
15 janvier
les 60% des à condom classer pour les
emplois à domicile c'est un des exemples
où la garde d'enfants et c est pour
quand on quand on adhère un syndicat par
exemple voilà donc donc 60% l'appui les
40 fonctions sans qui arriveront qui
arriveront après l'été ce qui est
important et square à des bugs pas de
bug
il ya tellement de personnes on peut
toujours se dire qu'on aura des endroits
où ça fonctionnera pas moi j'ai pris
contact avec les sociétés de ma
circonscription qui me disent
aujourd'hui monsieur le député tout va
bien dans l'ensemble
c'est plus à la limite des personnes qui
des salariés qui vont demander des
choses à l'employeur alors qu'elle
devrait le demander à l'administration
fiscale ça ça existe donc bien donc je
pense qu'il faut beaucoup de pédagogie
qu'il ya eu une erreur sur sur son taux
par exemple ou sur son prélèvement
pas besoin d'aller au service rh au
service paie de son entreprise c'est ça
et qu'elle a c'est l'administration
fiscale qui reste l'interlocuteur unique
et salariés des redevables et donc il ya
plusieurs canaux possibles pour prendre
contact avec administration il ya le
téléphone au 0 800 9 420 420 la
plateforme nationale il ya le site
internet bien sûr où on peut dans
l'espace gérer mon prélèvements la
source faire tout un tas de
modifications si la situation de famille
a changé naissances décès divorce etc
et si les revenus ont fluctué et puis en
dernier ressort on peut bien sûr se
rendre au guichet des finances publiques
geoffrey secula est ce que les
entreprises sont prêtes
concrètement vous ont dit que vous avez
eu le temps d'ailleurs la réforme a été
repoussée d'un angle est vrai il ya eu
les simulations du mois de décembre dans
beaucoup d'entreprises ça c'est pratique
et pour que pour conscientiser aussi le
salarié puis pour faire des essais
j'imagine pour les services paie et rh
qu'en est il aujourd'hui alors bien
évidemment on s'y est préparé puisque la
mesure est en vigueur depuis le 1er
janvier 2010
notre syndicat professionnel à
accompagner les entreprises en
organisant des formations en reliant
relayant également le kit pédagogique a
été élaboré par par l'état en
conseillant aussi aux entreprises de
faire des simulations de fiches de paye
au mois de décembre pour un est instauré
de la pédagogie également informé de
certains dispositifs comme le titre
emploi service entreprise qui existe
pour les entreprises qui ne sont pas
passés à l'adsl et qui peuvent déléguer
ce calcul du prélèvement à la source à
l'urssaf
ceci dit on a toujours des craintes et
ses craintes on verra effectivement si
elles sont légitimes à partir du mois de
février notamment sur le dialogue social
avec nos salariés puisque nos salariés à
poste équivalent s'ils effectuent le
même travail au sein de l'entreprise
auront un net après impôts qui pourra
être différent en fonction de leur foyer
fiscal
et c'est ce que retiennent les salariés
c'est le net qu'il touche
bien évidemment tous les mois et à ce
moment là on sera bien dans l'obligation
même si c'est du ressort de l'état de
donner des explications à nos salariés
expliqué pourquoi est ce qu'ils n'ont
pas le même salaire
c'est faivre picon du côté de la cgt on
était contre cette réforme est ce que ça
fait partie notamment des inquiétudes
oui c'est sûr que le net à payer va être
différent d'un salarié à l'autre ça va
complexifier les choses nous ce qui nous
remontent à la cgt notamment
c'est le fait qu'il ya un intermédiaire
de plus c'est-à-dire l'employeur et on a
effectivement certains salariés qui vont
voir leur drh pour faire modifier parce
qu'ils estiment que c'est pas normal ils
vont avoir 100 ou 200 euros de moins que
ce qu'ils avaient prévu sur leurs
feuilles de paye et on sait que c'est
pas possible puisqu'il faut aller voir
les services fiscaux et donc à la cgt on
est inquiet sur ce qui va se passer dans
l'entreprise mais aussi sur ce qui va se
passer dans les services fiscaux puisque
depuis plus de dix ans
les deux les emplois sont réduit petit à
petit en côte d'or c'est environ 25
emplois de moins par an tous les ans
depuis dix ans pour les l'ensemble des
services fiscaux avec 35 sites des
impôts essentiellement des trésoreries
qui ont été fermées en bourgogne franche
comté en bourgogne pardon et est donc
c'est énorme par rapport aux usagers et
donc la crainte que l'on est que l'on a
c'est que les citoyens qui vont avoir
besoin d'aller directement physiquement
dans un centre des impôts est du mal à
avoir des réponses rapides
l'administration nous garantit que les
changements pourront se faire en trois
mois
à la cgt on pense que ce sera plutôt six
mois et donc ce sera une gravissime pour
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une ligne
d'accord entre les patrons et les
syndicats de salariés au moins sur le
fait que finalement les entreprises vont
avoir plus de travail vont faire une
partie du travail de l'administration
fiscale comme collecteur d'impôts ce
qu'elles font déjà mais ce qu'elles vont
faire encore plus et que ça risque est
bien de toucher les emplois dans les
services publics et notamment les
services fiscaux benjamin diax non je
pense que déjà sion on a réussi à mettre
les salariés puis des patrons d'accord
c'est déjà une bonne réforme
puisqu'ils sont d'accord je suis
d'accord forcément ficultés blague
blague mise à part ce qu'il faut c'est
bien expliqué et là pour le coup tous
les syndicats ont un rôle à jouer bien
expliquer aux salariés ce qu'il en est
de quelle manière ils vont pouvoir
modifier leurs taux pas forcément se
rendent en physique pas ensemble des
impôts mais par pour ceux qui le
souhaitent par internet on peut avoir le
tout est individualisé non personnalisée
je veux pas rentrer dans tous les
détails mais savoir dans les six mois
non trois mois 3mois vraiment au maximum
si vous engagez vous à la direction des
services fiscaux de ce range absolument
s'en serait même plutôt au moyen de deux
mois et sur les emplois dans les
services fiscaux est ce que même si la
réforme était peut-être pas voulu pour
ça au départ qu'en plus c'est pas vous
qui l'avait imaginé mais la majorité
précédente
est ce que finalement vous vous dites
pas tant bien que mal on va faire des
économies sur les emplois dans les
services fiscaux non la rafale à la
forme est là jamais être fait pour ça
non mais les belles et pas du tout
apprécié cette phase on se dit alors que
puis alors surtout je pense on va
arriver au moment donné où on va voir la
réforme de l'ensemble des services
publics
alors je pense que s'il ya un mauvais
moyen pour attaquer cette réforme c'est
la prendre comme ça on a va l'apprendre
comme ça on se dire tiens on va
supprimer des postes à des pauses il y
en a qui l'ont essayé avant
ils ont eu des problèmes c'est pas comme
ça que ça fonctionne il faut qu'on voir
ensemble quand de quelle manière
d'ailleurs s'ils osaient aux
administrations elle même de voir de
quelle manière elles peuvent se réformer
celle qui le savent le mieux et elles
savent qu'elles doivent avancer par
rapport à ça aujourd'hui on a un service
je le redis une administration fiscale
qui est plus que compétentes pour mettre
cela en place
moi je tire mon chapeau ce sont quand
même les entreprises qui vont reprendre
une partie du travail des services
fiscaux joffrin secula ça va vous
prendre du temps et surtout ça coûte de
l'argent
ça coûte de l'argent et je dirai ce qui
est le plus dommageable également c'est
que cela va coûter plus cher pour des
tpe/pme des petites entreprises puisque
quand vous devez investir dans un
logiciel ou mettre à jour un logiciel ou
former des personnes qui vont travailler
sur sur le sujet est bien
cette charge vous l'a divisé par le
nombre de salaire que vous faites et
elle sera forcément plus importante
ramené au nombre de salariés pour une
tpe pme que pour une grosse entreprise
il faut aussi rappeler que pour les tpe
pme
un certain nombre d'entre elles
externalisent leur fiche de paye via
leurs experts comptables et là aussi
c'est un travail pour lequel logiquement
les experts comptables vont vont se
rémunérer donc c'est un coût
supplémentaire pour les entreprises une
simplification pour les usagers je
l'entends mais certainement pas pour les
entreprises et il y aura une souplesse
de l'administration fiscale pour les
entreprises les très petites entreprises
qui sont pas tout à fait prête ou qui
peuvent bégué par moment qu'il y aura
une tolérance tout à fait on a on a eu
des instructions pour que pour l'année
de mise en place en 2010 neuf on soit
plutôt dans l'accompagnement que plutôt
la sanction donc effectivement on sera
aux côtés des notamment des petites
entreprises qui n'ont pas encore basculé
sur l'adsl
il ya un dispositif alternatif qui
existent les proposé par l'urssaf
gratuit qui permet de remplir ses
obligations assez facilement il est
encore temps en janvier en février en
mars pour ces toutes petites entreprises
d'opter pour cette alternative est donc
remplir les obligations imposées par la
loi
benjamin dire qu'ici c'est ce que je
voulais évoquer pour les entreprises de
moins de 20 salariés
elles vont pouvoir passer gratuitement
directement par lui sauve c'est quelque
chose qui est important et vous avez
signalé autre chose c'est quand je dis
que l'administration enfin tous les
services publics doivent se réformer
quand j'entends parler d'accompagnement
c'est pas des choses qu'on entendait
auparavant
aujourd'hui on a une administration qui
va accompagner tout le monde accompagner
les entreprises pendant un an on a voté
aussi une loi qui le droit à l'erreur
on n'a pas voulu passer une loi sur le
droit à l'erreur pour dire on va mettre
des sanctions je crois que ça c'est de
cette manière là que l'administration
doit avancer et dans sur tous les sujets
pas que l'administration fiscale je
pense que c'est important on a compris
que c'est une réforme très technique
mais on voit bien que c'est une réforme
très politique dans un instant on
entendra gérald darmanin qui répondra
aux questions de de francis letellier
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission on sent qu'il marche sur des
oeufs gérald darmanin le contexte qu'on
évoquait au début de cette émission joue
beaucoup parce qu'on veut rendre on veut
ramener tout ça au contact d'ailleurs
vous vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
parliez d'un mouvement social je sais
pas si dans le mouvement social qui
existe aujourd'hui
ce serait intéressant de savoir combien
de personnes commun de pourcentage
payent l'impôt par rapport à ce moment
ce serait très intéressant
moi je pense pas qu'il ya un souci par
rapport à ça si on le ramène toujours
les choses par rapport à ça
effectivement mais allons plutôt de la
srx est un sujet sur lequel les français
sont sensibles
la fiscalité d'ailleurs vous êtes
référent fiscale pour la république en
marche sur le grand débat ça veut bien
dire que ça sera un des aspects du grand
débat les questions de fiscalité
j'allais dire heureusement puisque c'est
de là qu'est partie la question des
gilles et jeu donc ça va revenir dans le
débat il faut pas que s'il y avait des
bugs ça pourrait pourrir le grand débat
voyez ci reviendra dans le grand débat
si vous voulez toute réforme
ça fait toujours un petit peu peur une
réforme sont ou quelque chose comme ça
je vous disais ça fait mille neuf depuis
1914 que l'impôt le paye avec un an de
décalage
donc forcément que ça peut faire un peu
peur j'entends tout ce qui est dit moi
moi ce que j'ai envie de dire aussi
c'est quand même les entreprises ont
vraiment joué le jeu et quand vous êtes
aussi lanceurs d'alerté
attention il peut avoir un problème ça
c'est important et moi je dis il faut
continuer main dans la main c'est ce que
j'ai demandé aux entreprises de ma
circonscription
vous avez un souci à la fin du mois vous
allez faire remonter au service fiable
mais dites le nous aussi à nous
parlementaires
et si on peut jouer on ne sait quelque
chose on le sera mais il faut qu'on
fasse dans la concertation je crois
pardon et on a été plutôt plutôt écouté
puisque effectivement on a fait part de
nos craintes et on a des manques
demander une certaine mansuétude par
rapport à la mise en place de cette
réforme il faut reconnaître
qu'effectivement ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure monsieur concernant
l'accompagnement pour l'année 2019 elle
est véritablement nécessaire pour les
petites entreprises et petites et
moyennes entreprises
michel faivre picon sur sur ce mouvement
social est sûre sur le fait mon
maintenant la réforme elle est lancée
donc c'est parti moi moi je réussisse
sur le les suppressions d'emplois qui
ont déjà eu lieu et qui sont encore
annoncées pour l'année 2019 ce qui est
terrible dans justement cette cette
nouvelle réforme qui va faire bouger
beaucoup les choses qui va amener
forcément soit physiquement soit par
téléphone soit par internet beaucoup de
nos concitoyens à s'adresser à
l'administration fiscale
il ya besoin de maintenir les emplois
dans les dents les services fiscaux
voire même peut-être de les augmenter
dans un bon nombre d'endroits parce
qu'il va y avoir forcément des bugs et
des demandes des demandes importantes
pour faire modifier les taux de
prélèvement on a évoqué tout à l'heure
d'un maul à la question de l'effet
psychologique
on craint les économistes craignent que
ça joue sur la consommation sur sur la
croissance forcément dans les prochains
mois est ce que c'est l'inquiétude que
vous allez oui c'est une heure c'est une
inquiétude sur le mois de février
effectivement les économistes
s'attendent à une baisse de la
consommation du fait de la baisse du
revenu net qui va arriver sur la feuille
de paye de janvier et après
effectivement les négociations
salariales dans les entreprises vont
peut-être prendre une tournure un peu
différente
encore plus compliquée qu'elle ne
l'était avant et
à la cgt on sera là pour demander
d'oeuvrer augmentations de salaires vous
êtes conscient de ces deux éléments à la
fois la consommation des ménages et puis
les négociations salariales
ça peut jouer même si ça reste un peu
psychologique on est d'accord oui c'est
psychologique je vous ai expliqué tout à
l'heure ce qu'il en était maintenant
peut-être qu'on pourrait aller encore
plus loin et là les entreprises iront
peut-être encore on leur demande quelque
chose mais voyez vous comme fusionnel en
ag le l'impôt sur le revenu quand vous
parlez de sa fille fusionner la csg et
l'impôt sur le revenu les choses elle
existe et je vous expliquer de quelle
manière quand le président de la
république annoncé qu'ils en avaient
augmenté de 100 euros le smic sans que
ça tout coûte 1 euro aux entreprises
j'ai travaillé dessus et par une
augmentation du smic de 100 euros je
reviens sur les justement justement on
est revenu les propos du départ
d'augmenter de 100 euros et le smic
final ça coûte à l'employeur quand vous
regardez ce que vous pouvez faire on ne
pouvait pas toucher on essayait de le
faire aux cotisations salariales
puisqu'on était sur quelque chose qui
était anticonstitutionnelle le seul
moyen aurait été je fis justement de
fusionner la csg et l'impôt sur le
revenu mais donc on est passé par la
prime d'activité c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'elle avait été créé à l'époque
sous l'ancienne majorité
mais pourquoi imaginer moi sommes des
chefs d'entreprise qui me l'ont proposé
que cette prime d'activité puissent être
versés directement sur le salaire on
crée aujourd'hui un lien qui existe et
pourquoi pas aller jusque là on aurait à
ce moment là quelque chose
vous parlez d'une aide qui en bas de la
feuille on l'aurait quelque chose qui
serait tout de suite sur la feuille
chabot picon wissam oeuvrait agir
puisque effectivement une des craintes
que nous avons dans l'avenir c'est une
volonté de
du législateur de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des cotisations impôts prime
d'activité où toutes ces mesures
fiscales soit prélevée directement sur
la feuille de paye et donc qu'on arrive
à noyer les cotisations maladie les
cotisations chômage vont vous sépare les
cotisations et ça n'a pas le même charme
chic de cotisation doit être dédiée à
quelque chose les impôts c'est pour les
services publics c'est pour
l'organisation de le fonctionnement de
l'état partout et donc on doit pas
mélanger ça et donc on a une crainte
pour l'avenir qu'un jour il est il prêt
de l'idée à un gouvernement de modifier
ce système de cotisations et de la
soumettre au même niveau et de pouvoir
piocher dedans comme il l'entend m'a
jamais dire vous en défendez c'est pas
du tout ce que j'ai dit j'ai parlé de la
prime d'activité la prime d'activité
vous saviez vous devriez d'ailleurs être
d'accord avec ça vous avez non mais je
rigole pas il ya 25% des personnes qui
ne demandait pas cette prime d'activité
alors qu'elles y avaient droit y avaient
droit rendre automatique toutes ces
aides
c'est quelque chose d'important les
personnes qui veulent avant le coucher
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
communication et qui vont enfin la
touche alors qu'avant le demandez pas
ces postes 100 euros qu'elles vont avoir
d'augmentation s'étendent et ses 300
euros vous avez des personnes au smic
qu'il a à la fin du mois vont avoir 300
euros de plus parce qu'elle ne demandait
pas avant ce dont elle avait le droit
renom cela automatique je pense qu'on
peut tous se retrouver son rang sert de
ce match ça va faire encore plus de
travail pour les entreprises
certainement parce qu'on n'est pas dans
la simplification après je dirais toute
mesure qui vise à rémunérer le travail
pour nos salariés
on y est forcément favorable je dirais
l'accélération de la décision de de
mettre en place la défiscalisation des
eaux remettre en place la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
on y est forcément favorable puisque ça
permet de rémunérer rémunérer le travail
donc ça ce sont des avancées dans le
sens des entreprises aidées à se
rejoindre à toutes les entreprises que
je rencontre dans la circonscription me
disent je veux embauchée je trouve
personne
créons des grosses différences entre les
aides que dans la haie puis le salaire
est bien ce que je dis avec la prime
d'activité c'est une proposition que je
fais moi un benjamin dire allons encore
plus loin et
je pense que tout va sur les
conséquences de cette réforme sur le
pouvoir d'achat aussi sur les
négociations salariales dans les
prochains mois merci à tous d'avoir
accepté de répondre à ces questions et
de débattre en direct ce matin merci de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant le
point sur l'actualité régionale avec
emmanuel pinsonneault suivi de la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis letellier reçoit gérald darmanin
on parlera encore de l'impôt à la source
avec le ministre des comptes publics bon
dimanche sur france 3
[Musique]